the first story that we have is from the
from the Daily Mail China built a lab to
study SARS and Ebola in Wuhan and u.s.
biosafety experts warned in 2017 that a
virus could escape the facility that's
become key in fighting the outbreak so
here's that story's from over a week ago
and then we saw this this is from bio rx
IV Cold Springs Harbor Laboratory and
they say uncanny similarity of unique
inserts in the 20:19 and CoV spike
protein to HIV one gp120 n gag I have no
idea what any of this means the general
understanding that people actually let
me read what he says and we can just
kind of context clues the jargon
it says abstract we are currently
witnessing a major epidemic caused by
the 2019 at novel coronavirus
the evolution of 2019 and COV remains
elusive we found four insertions in the
spike glycoprotein which are unique to
the 2019 and CoV and are not present in
other corona viruses importantly amino
acid residues in all in all the four
inserts have identity or similarity to
those in HIV one gp120 or HIV one gag
interestingly despite the inserts being
discontinuous on the primary amino acid
sequence 3d modeling of the 2099 COV
suggests that they converge to
constitute constitute the receptor
binding site the finding of four unique
inserts in the 2019 NCO v all of which
have identity similarity to amino acid
residues in key structural proteins of
HIV one is unlikely to be fortuitous in
nature this work provides yet unknown
insights on the 2019 and CoV and sheds
light on the evolution and put
pathogenicity of the virus with
important implications for diagnosis of
the virus well if that's true it it
feels like it's a lot more than just a
corona virus or corona visors are
they're not that like we discovered them
in like the 70s right or something I
don't know yeah it's not even but here's
the thing right when you get a
sensationalist media that claims you
know you know trying to built this lab
you know to investigate this here's the
narrative that emerges
what people are NASA that are now saying
based on this non peer-reviewed public
you know study yeah or you know whatever
gonna call it I'm not trying to dismiss
it I'm just saying it's not like coming
out of Oxford or something okay
what people are thinking now here's the
theory the Wuhan lab was working on a
vaccine for SARS so they were
manipulating the virus they were doing
human trials to see if it work okay
someone who left was contagion it was
contagious and started infecting and
transmitted to other people that's the
that's the the like-liked conspiracy
theory okay what's his heavy one the
heavy one is that China working with the
Democrats released the virus to cause a
massive economic downturn resulting in
Donald Trump's loss in 2020 that's my
favorite one that you seriously have
heard this I swear to god I'm not
kidding yet Wow so the idea is that
something man the economy has took a hit
taking a hit it's down like 600 points
or something that the the market over
travel fears and the krona virus and I
swear to god there people online being
like the deep state needed China to
release this because the globalist and
it's like dude Wow
so so here's here's the thing right we
don't know anything right this report
about the HIV like I did some reading
I'm not an expert I'm not a viral just
epidemiology I don't any other stuff but
they but they're basically there's like
debates between actual scientists you
can see it on Twitter and stuff and
they're saying listen and even even the
ones who are leaning towards it looks
like it could be man-made
are saying there is a strong possibility
a in all likelihood this is just a
natural evolution just because it's not
likely to occur in nature doesn't mean
it didn't right so what they're doing is
I don't know I I did some general
digging into this like bio RX IV and
what I what I basically found is not
that it's like you know a publication of
disrepute or anything it's actually
looks like it's been going up it's
relatively new launched only six years
ago and it's just like a public
repository for papers that are right
here not peer-review this is important
not like I want to act like everyone in
the scientific community is somehow you
know guaranteed to be smart but at least
peer review is some kind
of protective barrier yeah so and I'm
not trying to you know insult any of
these researchers it's just we're so far
from knowing what this means and I think
there are a lot of people that profit
off of fear which which reminds me
today's sponsor is emergence I'm just
kidding but that's the point I'm making
right how many how many companies are
like people listen the virus is coming
to get you buy gold buy your emergency
food that you know what I'm talking
about you know that was when I was my
biggest criticisms of Jones is like
whenever he found a shocking apocalypse
mmm-hmm he had the perfect product to
protect your family of course they
didn't yeah so you know what it sounds
like for now is we don't know it's true
look at this story so it is absolutely
true that China built a lab to study
these and it's absolutely true well okay
let me calm down I'm saying absolutely
but it's been multiple reported by
multiple outlets that Wuhan had a lab
and there was concerns among the
international community there would be a
breach so now that you're having Wuhan
be its epicenter they tried claiming it
was you know from the animal meat market
but according to one study from you know
these Chinese researcher researchers the
first reported case happened before now
you want to know what gets real crazy of
course this is the favorite part my
favorite part of the conspiracy actually
actually did a segment on this from my
my Timmy has news channel mmm-hmm
China's arresting the whistleblowers
what are they whistleblowing so some
people in China doctors uh-huh
apparently came out early and said
they've been lying
it's worse than they're saying there's
one video of a woman saying was like
90,000 in fact it was a week ago or
something like that oh well so now
apparently I don't know look you a lot
of these stories are hard to know if
they're true or not but this story came
from Daily Mail which is you know news
guards certified whatever it's worth
saying that an expert has gone on the
record he has seen documents signed
saying they will no longer talk about it
China is basically is what they do man
yeah this is what was what worries me
about this because there's two things
that really worry me you have these
outlets that are like unfounded
conspiracies well hold on hold on look
this story about the Chinese lab that's
a real story yeah there there is a
pathogen it's a maximum security level
for bio lab research facility in
in women and there was a story look at
this it says are here but let me let me
let me redo I have pulled up scientists
warned in 2017 that a czars like virus
could escape a lab setup that year in
Wuhan China to study some of the most
dangerous pathogens in the world now
SARS like corona virus has infected more
than eight hundred there and this in
mind you this is a week ago this is a
little bit over a week ago
spread to at least ten other countries
and killed twenty five yeah not it's
it's over two hundred now and I think
somewhere in like healed over two
hundred yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
listen man you want to talk about
conspiracy theories let's talk about
conspiracy theories when someone tells
me that the deep states working with the
Chinese government to you know like beat
Donald Trump in November I roll my eyes
yeah somebody tells me that lizard
people are stealing moon cheese or
living you know in the North Pole I roll
my eyes if someone tells me that there
was a lab in China this is a real thing
yeah we were worried it was going to
there's gonna be a breach and now look
what's and now there's an infection
emerging in Wuhan mm-hmm I'm not gonna
immediately say it's true all you've
proven it and I think it's silly to
equally be like stop everybody it's
completely fake news no no no we just
say we don't know it's founded but keep
your eye on it yeah right it's founded
like it's it's an educated guess at this
point mm-hmm if you were to look I'll
tell you what man would you make a bet
of one dollar like if someone said I'll
bet you a dollar this is this is this is
true you'd be like I have reason to
believe that said that that is possible
yeah I would take that but but I mean I
want to bet around with people's life no
no I don't mean that I just mean like
yeah there's there's there's a lot of
circumstances where's like there's
there's literally no reason you would
gamble make sense like I'll put it this
way if someone asks you to bet on Donald
Trump being impeached would you do it no
no no way some people did apparently I
wouldn't I certainly wouldn't but on
this if depending on depending on the
odds like if someone was logical I'm
very logical and that that it seems like
it would make sense that they're
tweaking the virus they're trying to
figure out a vaccine vaccine for SARS
and and and it didn't work as planned
happen this happened you know but so
that's just speculation and I think
that's okay yeah like if you're gonna do
an investigation you've got to start
with an educated guess of some sort
yeah so if you're a journalist you're
sitting there looking at all these
pieces
well you got to investigate them and see
if they connect mm-hmm but you literally
have journalists right now mocking and
and and berating people who are asking a
question and I'm like this isn't this is
an insane conspiracy level stuff this is
literally them being like yep that labs
real now I'll tell you what's fueling it
let me show you this uh this next
article this one just just absolutely
did not help can an anti HIV combination
or other existing drugs out with the new
corona virus okay I am far from a
scientist who knows anything about the
stuff yeah but when you see a report
come out claiming there's HIV proteins
in this corona virus and then you see an
article claiming that an anti HIV drug
can actually combat it people who don't
know are gonna put these pieces together
and assume they're connected I don't
know if they are because for all I know
the way the anti HIV drugs has nothing
to do with the proteins on the virus
right but people are gonna see this and
they're gonna see the work you know to
see HIV on both and they're gonna be a
like boom here let's actually let's read
a little bit of this because this is
actually interesting and and we might
see a connection this is a science mag
reporting when a frightening new virus
of emerges in humans scientists spend
many months if not years developing and
testing a vaccine finding new treatments
- takes a long time but there's another
option
try existing drugs to see whether they
have activity whether they have activity
against the new virus in the case of the
novel coronavirus researchers are
already trying antivirals widely used to
treat HIV in hopes they might be able to
fight the corona virus as well other
still experimental antivirals including
one that was unsuccessfully tested
against ebola last year may also hold
promise so that's just the general idea
the reason i'm highlighting this is not
to say the connection it's actually to
refute there's a connection because
because i want to i want you know
basically say we don't know how
antivirals work like i don't and i mean
do they actually test these anti HIV
medicines or are they just speculating
is this more speculation that's what it
right looks like exactly and so so so
now here's where i want to go with it
how dare you media it always turns into
a how dare you media you know neighbors
we've we've actually got a lab and in
2017 fears over whether there could be a
breach and they're insulting the people
who asked the question
and then you you actually have science
you know science Matt come out and start
doing speculation I get it you know but
I'll tell you this what's more dangerous
telling people that's something that's
not tested could cure them when it could
actually cause side effects or not help
them at all or speculating as to how
this whole thing started I mean I could
see it makes sense you know try the
antibodies that are out there drugs that
are out there and see if they work if
they work awesome you know it makes
sense but it doesn't say that they're
actually trying these HIV drugs it well
I mean they I think they do actually I
think they mentioned that in Wuhan China
they have there's been a controlled
trial
they've already launched on yeah yeah
yeah but that's not the point is like I
I get it it you know it's a bit more
fair than I'm making it out to be so
I'll you know I'll tone down but I just
it really bothers me that you can make
an educated guess
or even just like trying to form an
opinion about how this may have begun
when no one knows is totally a
legitimate thing journalists are
supposed to be conspiracy theorists
right and then they're supposed to
disprove themselves or prove their
theory right I get it
you know conspiracy theory has become
like a bad word but journalists back in
the day used to think the worst about
major corporations and politicians yeah
and then go investigate and if they did
if they couldn't if it was wrong or then
they'd be like okay I was wrong yeah and
now it's like what do journalists do
they write about Brad Pitt's junk you
know it's like well I'm gonna do air
quotes for journalists so I don't know
you know I thought it was it would be an
interesting subject to talk about just
because you know that they're arresting
the whistleblowers I'll tell you what
man that is kind of frightening I think
it's a lot worse than they're making it
out to be and every day I think it's I
think it's even worse than I thought it
was the day before yeah I'm gonna go buy
some you know we're after this we're
gonna go get some water jugs and I'll
tell you this man you will never be able
to shame me into not taking care of
myself my friends and my family and
that's one thing I always tell everybody
it's it's hilarious to me that they're
like what are you approver you know it's
like what's wrong with prepping well I
mean not like the crazy people who have
bunkers in their backyards for like
nuclear apocalypse I'm talking about a
little much a couple 5-gallon jugs and
some like dry rice and just putting in
the in the cupboard you know I mean OSHA
Purdue but people know Chef Boyardee for
those I don't get the reference I was
joking about how like the other
day we went out and bought a bunch of
canned food and it was like Chef
Boyardee it lasts like six months or
something yeah it's like all bad it
didn't taste good anyway you know we
weren't thinking you know we just like
what we're gonna buy it but so I think I
think we we we kind of got to where we
could get on the store I suppose so
you